et à notre boîte vocale de passer de sept centimètres pour les primates
à entre 11 et 17 centimètres pour les humains.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la descente du larynx.
Et le larynx est la base de votre voix.
Quand un bébé humain naît, son larynx n'est pas encore descendu.
Cela n'arrive qu'au bout de trois mois.
Donc métaphoriquement, chacun d'entre nous ici
a revécu l'évolution de toute notre espèce.
Et à propos des bébés,
quand vous commenciez à vous développer dans le ventre de votre mère,
la première sensation ressentie du monde extérieur,
à seulement trois semaines, quand vous aviez encore la taille d'une crevette,
s'est faite à travers la sensation tactile
venue des vibrations de la voix de votre mère.
Comme on peut le voir, la voix humaine est assez importante
au niveau de l'espèce,
au niveau de la société -
c'est par là que l'on communique, que l'on crée des liens,
aux niveaux personnel et interpersonnel -
nous partageons par la voix bien plus que des mots et des données,
nous partageons en réalité qui nous sommes.
Et notre voix est indissociable de la manière dont les autres nous voient.
C'est un masque que nous portons en société.
Mais notre relation à notre voix n'est pas si évidente.
Nous utilisons peu notre voix pour nous ;
nous l'offrons à l'autre en cadeau.
C'est ainsi que l'on touche l'autre.
C'est une préparation dialectique.
Mais que pense-t-on de notre propre voix ?
S'il vous plaît, levez la main
si vous n'aimez pas le son de votre voix sur les répondeurs.
(Rires)
Voilà, merci.
La plupart des gens disent ne pas aimer le son de leur voix enregistrée.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Essayons de prendre dix minutes pour comprendre cela.
Je suis chercheuse au MIT Media Lab,
au sein du groupe Opéra du Futur,
et ma recherche porte sur la relation
que les gens ont avec leur propre voix et avec celle des autres.
J'étudie ce que nous pouvons apprendre de l'écoute de la voix,
dans différentes disciplines
comme la neurologie, la biologie, les sciences cognitives, la linguistique.
Dans notre groupe, nous créons des outils et des expériences
pour aider les gens à avoir une meilleure compréhension concrète de leur voix
afin de réduire leurs a priori,
d'avoir une meilleure écoute,
de créer des relations plus saines
ou juste de mieux se comprendre.
Et ça doit vraiment passer par une approche holistique de la voix.
Pensez à toutes les applications et implications
que la voix peut avoir, quand on commence à la connaître.
Votre voix est un phénomène très complexe.
Elle nécessite la synchronisation de plus de 100 muscles du corps.
Et en écoutant la voix,
on peut comprendre les possibles failles de ce qu'il se passe en nous.
Par exemple :
l'écoute de types très spécifiques de turbulences
et la non-linéarité de la voix
peut aider à déceler très tôt des cas de Parkinson,
à travers un simple coup de téléphone.
Écouter le souffle de la voix peut aider à déceler une maladie du cœur.
Nous savons aussi qu'un tempo qui change à l'intérieur d'un même mot
est un marqueur clair de dépression.
Votre voix est aussi très liée à vos niveaux hormonaux.
Des tiers écoutant des voix de femmes
ont été capables de placer les locutrices très précisément
dans leur cycle menstruel.
Juste grâce à l'acoustique.
Et aujourd'hui, avec les technologies qui nous écoutent en permanence,
Alexa d'Amazon Echo
pourrait réussir à prédire si vous êtes enceinte
avant même que vous ne le sachiez.
Alors il faut penser --
(Rires)
Il faut penser aux conséquences éthiques.
Votre voix est aussi très liée à votre manière de créer des relations.
Elle est différente pour chaque personne à qui vous parlez.
Si je prends un petit extrait de votre voix pour l'analyser,
je peux savoir si vous parlez à votre mère, votre frère,
votre ami ou votre patron.
On peut aussi prendre comme prédicteur la posture vocale.
Ou comment vous choisissez de placer votre voix pour parler à quelqu'un.
Et votre posture vocale, quand vous parlez à votre conjoint,
peut aider à prédire non seulement si, mais aussi quand vous divorcerez.
Donc il y a beaucoup à apprendre de l'écoute de la voix
et je crois qu'il faut commencer par comprendre
que nous n'avons pas une voix unique.
Je vais parler des trois voix que la plupart d'entre nous avons,
dans une modélisation appelée le masque.
Donc quand vous regardez le masque,
ce que vous voyez est la projection d'un personnage.
Appelons ça votre voix extérieure.
C'est aussi la manière la plus classique de penser la voix,
comme une manière de vous projeter dans le monde.
Le mécanisme de cette projection est bien connu.
Vos poumons contractent votre diaphragme
et cela crée une vibration autonome de vos cordes vocales,
ce qui produit un son.
Puis la manière dont vous ouvrez et fermez vos cavités buccales
fera que votre conduit vocal va transformer le son.
Donc tout le monde a le même mécanisme.
Mais les voix sont assez uniques.
C'est parce que d'infimes différences de taille, de physiologie
et de niveau hormonal
vont créer de subtiles différences dans votre voix extérieure.
Et votre cerveau est très fort pour capter ces subtilités
dans la voix extérieure des autres.
Dans notre laboratoire, nous tentons d'entraîner les machines
à comprendre ces subtiles différences.
Et nous utilisons l'apprentissage profond pour identifier en temps réel le locuteur
et sensibiliser sur l'usage de l'espace vocal partagé
- qui parle et qui ne parle pas aux réunions -
pour accroître l'intelligence de groupe.
L'une des difficultés ici, c'est que votre voix n'est pas statique.
On a déjà dit qu'elle change à chaque interlocuteur,
mais elle change aussi en général au cours de la vie.
Au début et à la fin de la vie, les voix d'homme et de femme sont très similaires.
Il est très difficile de distinguer
la voix d'une très petite fille de la voix d'un très petit garçon.
Mais entre les deux, votre voix devient un marqueur de votre identité fluide.
En général, pour les hommes, il y a un grand changement à la puberté.
Pour les femmes,
il y a un changement à chaque grossesse et un grand changement à la ménopause.
Donc tout ceci est la voix que les autres entendent quand on parle.
Alors pourquoi nous est-elle aussi étrangère ?
Pourquoi n'est-ce pas la voix que nous entendons nous-mêmes ?
Réfléchissons-y.
Quand on porte un masque, on ne voit pas le masque.
Et quand on essaie de l'observer, on n'en voit que la partie intérieure.
Et c'est votre voix intérieure.
Pour comprendre pourquoi elle diffère,
essayons de comprendre le mécanisme de perception de cette voix intérieure.
Votre corps va la filtrer de différentes manières
par rapport à la voix extérieure.
Pour percevoir cette voix, elle doit déjà atteindre vos oreilles.
Votre voix extérieure va voyager à travers l'air
alors que votre voix intérieure va voyager à travers vos os.
C'est la conduction osseuse.
À cause de ça, votre voix intérieure va sembler plus grave
et aussi plus harmonieuse musicalement que votre voix extérieure.
Une fois ce voyage effectué, elle doit accéder à votre oreille interne.
Et c'est là que commence un autre mécanisme.
C'est un filtre mécanique,
une petite séparation qui vient protéger notre oreille interne
chaque fois que nous produisons un son.
Cela réduit aussi ce que nous entendons.
Et puis il y a un troisième filtre qui est biologique.
Votre cochlée - la partie de votre oreille interne qui transforme le son -
est faite de cellules vivantes.
Et ces cellules vivantes vont s'activer différemment
selon la régularité avec laquelle elles entendent un son.
C'est un effet d'habitude.
À cause de cela,
comme votre voix est le son le plus entendu dans votre vie,
vous l'entendez en fait moins que les autres sons.
Enfin, il y a un quatrième filtre.
C'est un filtre neurologique.
Les neurologues ont récemment découvert
que lorsque vous ouvrez votre bouche pour produire un son,
votre propre cortex auditif s'éteint.
Donc vous entendez votre voix,
mais votre cerveau n'écoute en fait jamais le son de votre voix.
D'un point de vue évolutionniste, c'est sans doute logique,
puisqu'on sait cognitivement quel son nous produisons
et donc on n'a peut-être pas besoin de gâcher de l'énergie à analyser le signal.
On appelle cela la décharge corollaire
et cela concerne chaque mouvement de notre corps.
La définition exacte de la décharge corollaire
est une copie d'une commande motrice envoyée par notre cerveau.
Cette copie ne crée pas elle-même de mouvement
mais est en fait envoyée à d'autres régions du cerveau
pour les informer du mouvement à venir.
Et pour la voix, la décharge corollaire a aussi un autre nom.
C'est votre voix interne.
Donc récapitulons.
On a le masque, la voix extérieure,
à l'intérieur du masque, votre voix intérieure
et puis vous avez votre voix interne.
Et j'aime comparer celle-là au marionnettiste
qui tire les ficelles de tout le système.
Votre voix interne est
celle que vous entendez en lisant un texte en silence,
quand vous répétez pour une importante conversation.
Parfois elle est difficile à éteindre.
Il est très difficile de lire un texte écrit dans votre langue natale,
sans entendre la voix interne le lire.
C'est aussi la voix qui refuse d'arrêter de chanter
cette chanson idiote qui vous trotte dans la tête.
(Rires)
Et pour certaines personnes, il est même impossible de la contrôler.
C'est le cas des patients schizophrènes
qui ont des hallucinations auditives,
qui sont incapables de distinguer entre les voix venues de l'intérieur
et de l'extérieur de leur tête.
Dans notre labo, nous travaillons aussi sur des petits appareils
pour aider ces personnes à faire ces distinctions
et à savoir si une voix est interne ou externe.
On peut aussi penser à sa voix interne comme celle qui parle dans nos rêves.
La voix interne peut prendre de nombreuses formes.
Et dans vos rêves, vous libérez le potentiel de votre voix interne.
C'est un autre travail fait dans notre labo :
tenter d'accéder à cette voix interne dans les rêves.
Donc, même si vous ne pouvez pas toujours la contrôler,
vous pouvez toujours interagir avec elle,
par le dialogue, des dialogues internes.
Et vous pouvez même voir votre voix interne
comme le lien manquant entre pensée et actions.
Donc j'espère vous laisser avec une meilleure compréhension,
une nouvelle compréhension de toutes vos voix
et du rôle qu'elles jouent - en vous et en dehors -
car votre voix est un déterminant essentiel de ce qui vous rend humain
et de la façon dont vous interagissez avec le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)